it happened a few weeks ago this month
here at our cottage the standard typical
night for a busy night we're doing just
roasting chicken and mr. chicken and it
was just just an amazing surprise it was
so sweet and natural and very romantic
he got on with me an instant yes from
you yes as a matter of fact I could
barely let me finish proposing us what
can I say yes ma'am and then those hugs
and I have the ring in my finger and I
was like can I can I give you the ring
shoes is the ring so no resume it was a
really nice moment just the two of us
and I think I managed to catch some
ketchup by surprise as well yeah and
this is how long after you first met oh
it would be a year-and-a-half do a
little bit more than that no just by
which for most people would be quite a
whirlwind is that how it felt to you I
don't think that I would call it a
whirlwind in terms of our relationship
obviously they've been layers attached
to how public it has become after we had
a good five six months almost with just
privacy which was amazing but no I think
we were able to really have so much time
just to connect and we never went longer
than two weeks without seeing each other
even though we were obviously doing a
long-distance relationship so it's um we
made it work how did you first meet yes
we first met we were introduced actually
by a mutual friend who we will we should
protect our privacy well too much of
that and but it was it was actually it
was through her and then we met once and
then twice back-to-back two dates in
London
last July yes I can't even July and then
it was I think about three maybe four
weeks later that I managed to persuade
her to come and join me in Botswana and
we we camped out with each other under
the stars and we spent a majority for
five days out there which was absolutely
fantastic so then we were really by
ourselves
mm-hmm which was crucial to me to make
sure that we had a chance to get to know
each other yeah but the friend who
introduced you was she trying to set you
up yes it was definitely a setup
it was a blind date and it's so
interesting because we talked about it
and now and even then I you know because
I'm from the States you don't grow up
with the same understanding of of the
royal family and so while I now
understand very clearly there's a a
global interest there I didn't know much
about him and so the only thing that I
had asked her when she said she wanted
to set us up was had one question it's a
voice he nice because if he wasn't kind
it just didn't it didn't seem like it
would make sense and so we went and had
a mat for a drink and then I think very
quickly into that we said what are we
doing tomorrow we should meet again
represent or let's meet again and then
it was like write Diaries we need to get
the Diaries out and find out how we're
gonna make this work because I was off
to Africa for a month she was working
and we just said right where's where's
the gap and the gap happened to be the
perfect place so how much did you piss
her II know about Megan had you seen her
on TV no I'd never never even heard
about her until this friend said make a
mark was like write a cake give me give
me a bit of background so no I'd never
I'd never watch suits I'd never heard of
Megan before and I was beautifully
surprised when I walked into that room
and saw her and there she was sitting
there I was like okay why agree after I
got my game made sure I got a good shot
I think for both of us so it was it was
really refreshing because given that I
didn't know a lot about him everything
that I've learned about him I learned
through him as opposed to having grown
up around different news stories or
tabloids or whatever else anything I
learned about him and his family was
what he would share with me and vice
versa so for both of us it was just a
really authentic and organic way to get
to know each other and was that quite
refreshing for you in the way that
you've been brought up you know with a
lot of people knowing a lot about you
was it refreshing thinking very nice
thinking things Eric yeah no it's a
hugely refreshing to be able to get to
know someone who isn't necessarily
within your circle doesn't know much
about me I don't know about much about
her
so to be able to start almost afresh
right from the beginning and getting to
know each other step by step and then
taking that huge leap of any two dates
and then and then going together in the
middle of nowhere and you know showing
it showing a tent together and all that
kind of stuff it was there was it was
fantastic it was absolutely amazing to
get to know her as quickly as I did and
starting a long-distance relationship
you were working on suits you had I
imagine a packed filming schedule you've
got lots of commitments of your own how
hard was it to keep things going it was
just a choice right I think that very
early on when we realized we were going
to commit to each other and we knew we
had to invest the time and the energy
and whatever it took to make that happen
and so yes with the filming schedule it
was not the easiest because it of course
included a lot of travel back and forth
but I don't think you had any idea what
times only be home for last year and a
half no over here four days or week and
then going back and then straight into
filming the next day 4:00 a.m. wake-up
calls it on Monday yeah straight into
cert you know right off the plane and
straight to set you just kind of just
trying to stay as close as possible but
you know on two different time zones and
five hours apart does have its
challenges but then you know remain here
working and now we're here so in the
case of your relationship unlike for
most people there's this whole layer of
what it means to get involved with
someone from the Royal
how much of a sense did you have Meaghan
of the enormity of what you were getting
into what it might mean for your life I
think I can very safely say as naive as
it sounds now having gone through this
learning curve in the past year and a
half I did not have any understanding of
just what it would be like I don't think
either of us did that we both said that
even though we knew that it would be I
tried I tried I tried to warn I tried to
warn you as much as possible but I think
both of us were totally surprised by the
reaction after the first five six months
of when we had to ourselves of what
actually happened from then so I think
you can you can have as many
conversations as you want and try and
prepare as much as possible but we were
we were totally unprepared for what
happened after that
the scrutiny was well I mean I think
also because there's a misconception
that because I have worked in the
entertainment industry that this would
be something I would be familiar with
but even though I've been on my show for
I guess six years at that point and
working before that I've never been part
of tabloid culture I've never been in
pop culture to that degree and and lived
a relatively quiet life even though I
focused so much on my job and so that
was a really stark difference out of the
gate but and I think we were just hit so
hard at the beginning with a lot of
mistruths that I made the choice to not
read anything positive or negative it
just didn't make sense and instead we
focused all of our energies just on
nurturing our relationship yes and some
of that scrutiny and you ended up making
a very public statement about if some of
that scrutiny was centered around your
ethnicity again when you realize that
what did you think of course it's
disheartening you know it's it's a shame
that that is the climate in this world
to focus that much on that or that that
would be discriminatory in that sense
but I think you know the end of the day
I'm really just proud of Who I am and
where I come from and we have never put
any focus on that we've just focused on
who we are as a couple and so when you
take all those extra layers away and all
of that noise
is I think it makes it really easy to
just enjoy being together and you tune
all the rest of that out but now that it
is all official Prince Harry do you have
that sense that the combination of the
two of you your different backgrounds
that you together represent something
new for the royal family
I mean you I think it's a you know it's
a for me it's a an added member of the
family it's another another team player
as part of the the bigger team and you
know for all of us what we want to do is
be able to carry out the right
engagement stereo or work and try and
encourage others and the younger
generation to be able to see the world
in the correct sense rather than perhaps
being just having a distorted view so
you know the fact that I thought that I
fell in love with Megan so incredibly
quickly was a sort of confirmation to me
that everything everything all the stars
are aligned everything was just perfect
it was this beautiful woman just sort of
literally tripped and fell into my life
I've run into her life and the fact that
she III know the fact that she'll be
really unbelievably good at the job part
of it as well is obviously huge relief
to me because she'll be able to deal
with with everything else that comes
with it but um no you know we're a
fantastic team we know we are and and
what we hope to over time try and have
as much impact for the things that we
care about as much as possible I am very
excited and making given your your
acting in the profile you had you'd
already been involved of various causes
you've been an ambassador for UN when
what about this new role I mean you're
going to have an a bigger platform a
bigger voice what do you want to do with
it I mean houses I think what's been
really exciting as we talk about the
transition of this out of my career but
into the role is that as you said the
causes that have been very important to
me I can focus even more energy on
because very early out of the gate I
think we realized once you have access
or a voice that people are willing to
listen to with that comes a lot of
responsibility which I take seriously
and at the same time I think in these
beginning few months and now being boots
on the ground in the UK I'm excited to
just really get to know more about the
different communities here smaller
organizations we're working on the same
causes that I've always been passionate
about under this umbrella and and also
being able to go around to the common
well if I think it's just just the
beginning of that there's a lot to do
there's a lot to do and it's an immense
change you're you're getting a new
country out of it as a husband obviously
but also giving up giving giving up your
career yes but I don't see it as giving
anything up I just see it as a change a
challenge I mean there's a new chapter
right and and also keep in mind I I've
been working on my show for seven years
so we are very very fortunate to be able
to have that sort of longevity on a
series and for me once we hit the
hundred episode marker I thought you
know what I have I have ticked this box
and I feel really proud of the work I've
done there and now it's time to as he
said work work as a team but do you have
that sense of responsibility Prince
Harry for what you thought you were
asking Megan to do of course that sense
of responsibility was it was essentially
from day one or maybe a couple of months
in when I saw they realized actually
this is you know I feel I know that I'm
in love with this girl and I hope that
she's in love with me but we still had
to sit down on the sofa and I stopped
you know I still had to have some pretty
you know frank conversations with that I
said
you know what you're letting yourself in
for is it is it's a big it's a big deal
and it's you know it's not I wouldn't
it's not it's not easy for anybody but I
know that you know she she chooses me
and I choose her and therefore you know
whatever whatever we have to tackle
together or individually it will always
be us together as a team so I think I
think she's she's capable of she's
capable of anything and together as I
said this there's a hell of a lot of
stuff and work that needs doing at the
moment for us it's going to be making
sure that our relationship is always put
first but know that both of us have
passions for you for wanting to make
change change for good and you know with
lots of young people running around the
Commonwealth that's where we're gonna
spend most of our time anything and it
was really one of the first things we
connected on it was one of the first
things we started talking about when we
met was just the different things that
we wanted to do in the world and how
passionate we were about seeing change I
think that was um that's what got date 2
in the books probably plenty to talk
about children no not currently no no of
course you know that I think you know
one one foot one step at a time and if
you will will start a family in the near
future I think you've met each other's
families imagine yes his family's been
so welcoming and and you look or feel
emotion I have on both sides of his
families mom's side as well which has
been really important to me too but yes
the family has been great and over the
past year and a half we've just had a
really nice time getting to know them
and progressively helping me feel a part
of of not just the institution but also
part of the family which has been really
really special trying to track them down
and make sure they're around at the same
time that she's popping in without
telling too many people and we've done
incredibly well
to make sure the internet or key people
so doesn't mean a lot of the time and
that you've been together in this last
year and a half you've been you've been
at home a lot yes yeah we've we've well
yeah we had to reverse the whole process
and Thursday nights in in from the
television cooking dinner with just the
two of us by ourselves and on the
cottage
rather than going out for dinner and
being seen in public so we have we
reversed the whole process which is it's
it's it's provided different
opportunities and that has made us a
hell of a lot closer to shorter space of
time like a champ that's you know
without question so you know slow down
the dates and maybe spend more time but
I mean you know it's it's for us it's
it's an opportunity to to really get to
know each other without other people you
know looking or trying to take photos on
their phones and all that kind of stuff
you know with that that comes that comes
comes with a it comes with a job comes
to the role but I'm responsible yeah and
we were able to really get to know each
other that way but also then to go and
have friends over for dinner or to go to
his family's tea or any of those sort of
things and even you know just to take
the take the time to be able to go on
long country walks and just have you met
the Queen I have times it's incredible I
think you know a to be able to meet her
through his lens not just with his honor
and respect for her as the monarch but
the love that he has for her as his
grandmother all of those layers have
been so important for me is that when I
met her I had such a deep understanding
and of course incredible respect for
being able to have that time with her
and and we've heard her really she's
she's an incredible woman and the cool
news to you straight away 33 years been
Balto
just laying on my feet during that has
to be of a good sign speaking of dogs
have you brought yours today
well I have two dogs that I've had for
quite a long time both my rescue pups
and one is now staying
with very close friends and my other
little guy is yes he's in the UK he's
been here for a while okay let's hope he
adjust well I think he's doing just fine
what was it like introducing Megan to
your father and your brother like it was
exciting I mean I I've been seeing her
for a period of time when I literally
didn't didn't tell anybody at all and
then William was longing to meet her and
so is Catherine so you know the being
our neighbors we managed to get get that
in a couple of well quite a few times
now and Catherine's been absolutely
amazing as William as well you know
fantastic support and then my my
father's already you know top of more
than that we've had a handful of teas
and meetings and and all sorts of
gatherings over at his place as well so
know the family together have been
absolutely you know solid support and my
grandparents as well have been having
wonderful throughout this whole process
and they've known for quite some time so
how they how they haven't told anybody
again a miracle in itself but neither
the whole family have come together and
and have been a huge amount of something
they've been amazing and making your
parents do you think you know well very
happy for you obviously do you think
they have worried at all about the scale
of what you're getting into
well I'm sure at the onset both my
parents and my close friends were
concerned because we got very quickly
swept up in a media storm that as a I
shared was not part of my life before
that but they also had never seen me so
happy and and I think also once my
friends excuse me we're able to to
really meet Harry and my mom we would
spend a lot of time with it was so much
fun was amazing it was just you know it
was just obvious that no matter what we
were being put through that it was just
temporary and that we were going to be
able to get through that so everyone was
really happy believe he's talked to my
dad
few times hasn't been able to meet him
just yet but it's all been it's all been
worth every effort mmm
and your ring oh yeah tell us about your
ring the ring is is obviously yellow
gold because that's her favorite and the
main stone itself a sauce from Botswana
and the little diamonds either side are
for my mother's jury collection to make
sure that she's with us on this on this
crazy journey together and it's
beautiful and he designed it it's
incredible yeah yeah stays on that
finger what does it mean to you Megan to
have those stones on your finger that
once belonged to Princess Diana I think
everything about Harry's thoughtfulness
is and the inclusion of that and
obviously not being able to meet his mom
it's so important to me to to know that
she's a part of this with us and and I
think in being able to meet his aunts
and and also to be like Julia and just
different people who are so important to
his mom I'm able to in some way know a
part of her through them and of course
through him and it's it's incredibly
special and you know to be able to have
this which sort of links or you come
from and what's one of which is
important to us and it's it's perfect
what do you think your mother would have
thought of Megan or said about Megan is
there because there's without question
I'm sure it to be over the moon jumping
up and down you know I was so excited
for it for me but then as I said it
would have probably been best friends
best friends with Megan so now it's I
you know it's in these days like days
like today when when I really miss
having you around and miss being able to
show that the happy news but you know
with the ring and with everything else
that's going on I'm sure she's seizing
I'm sure she's with us you know you know
jumping up and down somewhere else